[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes brought to you by spectator tv
and broadcast on thursday february 24th
i'm katie balls the spectator's deputy
political editor and your host this week
on this week's show
russia has invaded ukraine and on
thursday morning launch attacks across
the country including in the capital of
kiev
i've got the latest from james forsyth
and kate andrews hear about what drives
vladimir putin from owen matthews and
the historian orlando fija's and discuss
what we can learn from the cold war with
the author and former pentagon advisor
hal brans
after all that we'll turn to covert
the last legal restrictions were lifted
this week matt ridley will tell us what
he thinks and will discuss respiratory
diseases like covid and whether they
become milder over time
and to finish we'll look to canada
why has justin trudeau decided to use
emergency powers to stop the trucker
protests
before we get going a very special thank
you to canaccord generity wealth
management who are sponsoring the week
in 60 minutes
canaccordo experienced wealth planners
and investment managers who go above and
beyond to offer you support and guidance
just visit candywealth.com to find out
more
remember to subscribe to our youtube
channel too click the red subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon to make sure you never
miss an episode
in the early hours of this morning
russia invaded ukraine bombarding the
country of air strikes and troop
deployments from the north south and the
east
to talk through the latest and give us
an insight into what pewter might be
thinking i'm joined by owen matthews the
spectator's russia correspondent and the
historian orlando features
owen orlando thanks for joining
spectator tv
oh and in this week's magazine you
wonder whether
ultimately putin has lost the plot are
you surprised by his decision to launch
a full-scale invasion of ukraine um i'm
i'm not just surprised
i'm completely flabbergasted but
actually more importantly than me
i've just spent the whole morning
on twitter and signal and facebook and
uh with all my russian contacts several
many of whom have worked in the putin
apparat in the diplomatic service in the
in his media machine
for two decades and russians are amazed
i mean people who think they know what's
going on you know top journalists people
who work for putin in the kremlin who
have been supporting his propaganda
effort for years
they are surprised and they actually
didn't think it was going to happen
basically sunday everyone was still on
the diplomatic
channel lavrov you know everyone was
all
calling
western claims of intermittent invasion
hysteria
and then it suddenly changed and there's
two explanations to that either
that the diplomacy was a bluff and raw
war was a plan all along
but um
or that uh
something changed in principle and putin
decided at the last minute for reasons
that are very hard to fathom to
completely abandon not just diplomacy
but apparently
all kind of self-interest because i
think what we one thing that we have
been saying all along uh both orlando
and i is actually true is that the one
scenario in which he absolutely loses
all the diplomatic leverage that he has
all of the
strategic ambiguity that he's built up
all the allies that he's been
cultivating inside europe and his divide
and conquer
all of that he loses with a full scale
invasion and he's invaded it's totally
inexplicable and
completely
counterproductive as i see it well andy
are you also perplexed by recent events
yes i'm shocked and saddened and
disgusted um as everybody is um
and we're at a point where we really
can't tell what's in putin's planning
we can certainly tell what he's been
reading and what he's been saying and
the sort of ideologies that
he's been
playing with that have led him to this
point um i think
that he has uh moved in an imperial
direction
terms of sort of civilizational thinking
he's taken on board a lot of ideas from
uh people like carl schmidt to believe
that
uh
there are hegemonic states of which
russia is one and there are other
entities like ukraine which are not even
to be given
uh sovereign status
um so he's been perhaps isolated too
long reading too many weird nazi jurists
and other ideologists of a pan-slav
eurasian ilk that would lead him in this
direction to think that he is able to do
this
is that a sign of madness of dislocation
from reality uh
i think probably it is
in which case i think like many uh
russian rulers of that nature that have
embarked on foreign adventures before
and i'm thinking of nicholas the first
and the first crimean war
it will mean the end of his regime
fairly quickly
on the other hand um all the signs are
and the confidence of the rhetoric would
suggest that they've been planning this
for a very very long time so i think
that he still has a lot of levers to
pull he still has a lot of influence to
call upon and he still has a number of
threats to make perhaps even to our own
political establishment or any political
establishment that tries to cross him so
you know this is a kgb war as well as a
ministry of defense war um and it's it's
a war in which everything is weaponized
um disinformation social media cyber
warfare as well as troops on the ground
and and all the deployments we've seen
in the last few hours
so
who knows who knows where we are it's it
would be a fool now to say that they
thought they knew what was going to
happen next
and all andrew just on the historical
perspective here i want him you
mentioned how ultimately putin um
in how he is speaking and how he sees
things he's suggesting that ukraine is
not a country it's part of greater
russia effectively um can you talk us a
bit more through his perspective on this
and ultimately where greater russia ends
yeah well i mean the the article that
everyone cites is his long piece
slightly bizarre piece that the kremlin
published last year july 2021
and uh he's really repeating a number of
strands that he's already made in his in
in his speeches and articles
namely that
russia and ukraine and belarus are all
one nation they all share the same
foundation and kievan ruse
um so we saw this really come to the
fore in 2016 when he opened this
monument to the grand prince vladimir in
moscow who of course is also claimed by
the um uh ukrainians as the founder of
their european state for putin he's the
founder of the great russian state of
which a tripartite state if you like of
which belarus and ukraine are one so
this is his civilizational thinking i
was referring to
and in that foundation myth there's no
place for a ukrainian statehood this
again is something that you know the
ideas of carl schmidt that he's been
borrowing from uh feed into the idea
that that um
only certain cultural national
formations have statehood at their heart
so russia has a statehood and ukraine
has always been for putin um just a
borderland ukraine the the original slav
word for ukraine just does mean
borderland and so it's uh and then in
other articles putin has said for
example that you know ukraine as a
nation state was invented by the
bolsheviks so
that
you can see given the historiography he
comes from basically soviet you can see
sort of where he's coming from i mean
it's mad but his argument is that it was
only uh the bolsheviks in drawing up the
constitution of the soviet union that
ukraine was given its first nation well
the ukrainians would say nonsense they
they would trace their nationhood back
to kievan rus or they would trace their
nationhood back to the cossack
heckmanate of the 17th century which
looked for help from russia originally
or they would point to the independent
ukraine of 1917 to 18 which very quickly
became a german puppet state and then
got embroiled in civil war before the
the uh soviet union was formed with a
soviet republic as part of it so uh
ukrainian soviet republic so you can see
that it's a whole mishmash of historical
ideas and ideologies
that putin is weaponizing here or
drawing from to justify his his world
view of russia as a hegemonic state in
ukraine as simply
um a subordinate state if you like or
subordinate entity which which has to be
included in a bigger civilization that's
how i think he he views the world
um and it's it is wacky it is it is mad
it is certainly not fit for purpose in
in in a post-1991 world where we do live
by um we hope you know international
standards and principles of sovereignty
um but that is just not how putin
um has come to see it um unfortunately
and owen where is i suppose russian uh
public opinion on this is there a sense
amongst the people that you know ukraine
is a part of russia or you know should
be uh more in locksync with it well um
uh well first i mean just to orlando's
point i mean something um an analogy
that might be more familiar to
english or british uh viewers is
actually the very ambiguous relationship
between britain in the first world war
and ireland for instance or a longer
term the the the scottish kingdoms
flirtation with france it's always the
the relationship between russia and
ukraine is of close neighbors which have
various points being part of the same
state which have been flirting with
enemies and are flirting with enemies
now the the the really big question is
uh
will
russia's very rushed very amateurish
very last minute
propaganda campaign managed to swing
a majority of russian opinion behind
a full-scale invasion i don't think so
far
i personally don't believe that a
long-term occupation of all of ukraine
is anything that vladimir putin is
contemplating it's certainly not what
he's preparing his people for uh but the
uh
clearly defending donbass and the
russians of the eastern ukraine against
genocide is now the line
depressingly it seems that russian
viewers claim in public opinion surveys
to be
quite fantastically gullible and with
the program so the very latest polls
that have come out say that 50 percent
uh at least support the war but um the
the reliability of polls is always a big
this is always a big question mark
because for instance the uh
eom the
state-controlled polling center not the
independent lavada one but literally the
state-controlled one uh came up with a
poll when they open-endedly ask
poor russians to name a political
politician they trust only 21 say
vladimir putin when you ask them on a
multiple choice which of these
politicians you trust most then putin
comes out at 68
so is his support 21 or is it 68 it
depends how you ask the question it's a
very ambiguous
issue um now so far um
the messaging has in the past
worked in 2008 it was a question of the
georgians have attacked south ossetia
and the russian public were able to
believe that package which was in fact
somewhat true the georgians did attack
south africa briefly um that russia was
responding to a provocation in crimea
there was a gigantic preamble there was
actually three months of
profound unrest in kiev
the
revolution of dignity as the ukrainians
call it the the
effectiveness of democratic people power
coup against the pro-russian government
of viktor yanukovych was presented as a
fascist coup and there was lots of time
to prepare the russians for that here
all of those arguments about the
fascists in in in kiev about aggression
has been compressed into 48 hours
it's amazingly rushed it's as though
they've just sort of decided to sort of
run out of the building and just grab
every single ideological argument that
they have and off the shelf and just
sort of throw it
at the russian public and see
what will happen and whether it'll stick
i mean i think that there is a profound
uh ambiguity uh and there's a
ambivalence i would say between the
relationship in the relationship between
russians and ukrainians because they
actually have so many ukraine russians
have close family ties with ukraine i
mean they
do indeed consider ukraine to be part of
their own country in many ways and
that's a very common attitude that it's
just a little part of our of our great
nation
um but that argument has to
that that's a stick with two ends as the
russians say is that um
the russians consider it part of their
country does that mean that they're
actually going to
allow their sons or be happy about their
sons
going to war against ukrainian ordinary
people i don't know it's the most i mean
what the one thing it is clear is that
this is the most severe
and extreme stress test that russian
propaganda has ever had to face
and
if putin loses it
then that really is the end of his
regime
and and he's he's started it in an
extraordinarily rushed amateurish way
which has amazed and shocked even most
russians even those that even many
russians who support him and owen just
briefly on that one of the points you've
made when you've been covering this
crisis is that
you thought uh a full-scale invasion was
unlikely because ultimately putin had
not been preparing the people for it
have we seen in the past you know few
days and start to do that do you think
the russian people are prepared for the
war that he has now announced
well that's um that the messaging has
changed i mean it hasn't changed to
let's incorporate
uh ukraine into russia that's not the
messaging
the messaging is let's defend the the
russians of eastern ukraine from
fascists and genocidal killers in the
form of
uh ukrainian nationalists
so i mean even at the moment uh
even now that there's been this sort of
step change this complete sort of pivot
towards an actual invasion the messaging
in russian state media is still not a
full-scale invasion it's about
publishing the
fascists for
launching an aggressive war as the
russian media has been portraying it
against the russian-speaking peoples of
eastern ukraine
and orlando just finally um if we have a
situation where we talked a lot about
the risk here in terms of uh you know
putin announcing this where it could go
very wrong for him why this is by far
one of the most tricky paths he could
have picked the most difficult in fact
but were this to go to plan for putin
what does that look like and what is he
trying to do in terms of
writing his legacy and changing russian
history
well we don't know what his plan is i
mean uh
so we can't really say but the
i think owen's point is a good one about
um
you know support whether this would be
um coming from the russian population i
mean still 70 percent of the population
is entirely dependent on television for
its news
so he can control that increasingly aged
part of the population
um but i i'm
but i'm i
and i'm skeptical about whether um
there's a going to be a big anti-war
movement in russia because he's crushed
civil society so effectively and it's so
fragmented that people have become
despondent so we'll see we'll see about
that whether he can see it through um
and i don't think there can be a success
for putin from from this point on and
and i i i think and very much hope it
spells the end of its regime
and i suspect coming back to this this
rhetoric of defending the russian people
from genocide et cetera i suspect that
that has actually more to do with
putin's own
uh weirdly twisted reading of of
post-cold war history and his his
his attempt to get back at the west for
what he sees probably as the beginning
of all of this confrontation with the
west which is kosovo because if you
remember it nato went into kosovo uh
supposedly to save the albanians from
genocide uh from the serbian philosophy
treasury and i think that's the point at
which the russians see the beginning of
this uh new confrontation this new cold
war if you like with the west so it's
almost as if he's saying we
as if he's saying to the west in his own
um ideological thinking his echo chamber
as as owen put it in his piece is what
mrs if he's saying to the west you know
i'm going to fight you by
by your own principles i'm going to call
out the genocide your your your your
your you're bringing about to our
russian speakers our people as he would
put it um although they're of course uh
citizens of a sovereign state um and and
this is um so now divorced from reality
that one wonders who it's going to
convince um other than himself and and
um the sort of mad ideologists who
surround him or who've been um
influencing his thinking
and i doubt even whether it will
convince i mean will lavrov really be
convinced by this sort of um rhetoric as
uh the occupation of ukraine becomes
more uh more and more bloody and messy i
don't know i suspect it will probably
uh accelerate any fragmentation of his
own regime between you know hawks and
doves between those who may want to
return to the diplomatic path
rather than uh get russia
deeper and deeper into this mire
into which it's now launched itself
thank you orlando thank you owen
what does the invasion mean for a
relations between russia and the west
and what can we learn from the cold war
the last time the west had to confront
the kremlin
i'm joined by james forsythe our
political editor and hal brandes a
former pentagon advisor and the author
of the twilight struggle what the cold
war teaches us about great power rivalry
today
how your book the trial struggle looks
at what we can uh learn from the cold
war in terms of relations with russia
and china today
um what do you make of this uh
i think someone said you know there's a
blossoming relationship between uh
russia and china in recent weeks and
months
i think the best way to conceive of this
is that russia and china are pursuing
parallel and
perhaps increasingly convergent
challenges to the international system
and so both of them are challenging the
united states for their own reasons and
so they don't necessarily have to get
together in order to do that but they
are getting together in a more
significant way and so we've seen
growing cooperation in the economic
diplomatic technological and military
realms of of a sort i think that would
have surprised many
western observers had it been predicted
10 to 20 years ago
at the same time it simply the existence
of the other countries challenge makes
life easier for beijing or moscow and so
the fact that the russians are putting
pressure on western positions in ukraine
and eastern europe creates distraction
that beijing can profit from in the
western pacific
and vice versa and so this isn't a
formal alliance but it doesn't actually
need to be a formal alliance to cause a
lot of strategic headaches for the west
and how what do you think we can learn
from the cold war looking ahead to
as you mentioned you know which might
not be so different if you're looking at
the various tensions in going forward
well i think one of the more sobering
lessons is that while we would certainly
like to drive wedges between russia and
china that's probably not going to be
possible for the time being this is
perhaps a negative lesson from the cold
war and so everyone wants to pull the
reverse kissinger to find a way of
peeling putin away from xi jinping and
using him as a tool of containing china
what we often forget is that the earlier
sino-soviet
split preceded the u.s opening to china
and it wasn't until china and the soviet
union fought a fairly sharp border war
in 1969 that that u.s opening to china
became possible the the hard fact of the
matter is that while there are tensions
and there are divergent interests
between russia and china today there's
nothing on the scale of tensions that
would
convince putin to fundamentally reorient
russian strategy those tensions may come
to the surface over time that's what
happened during the cold war but i think
we're talking about something that might
manifest during the 2030s in a
post-putin era rather than today and
james is the west is ready for this uh
you know a so-called great power rival
as they were for the cold war
i i think not i think defense spending
is low and i think that there is a
question about uh
western you know if you look at european
countries they have essentially spent
their cold war peace dividend on health
and welfare spending it's very hard to
unwind that with aging populations so
how do you do that and then i think
there is also the fact that europe is
going to have to take a lot more
responsibility for its security
i think you know we are seeing a gradual
u.s withdrawal from europe as it has to
focus more on the threat that china
poses to it uh in in in the pacific as
hao was saying and so you know you look
at the role that biden has played in
this crisis you know the pressure he put
on germany to cancel nordstrom 2 the
rallying effect that u.s diplomacy has
had you know european powers are going
to have to start doing that for
themselves and that is that is going to
be a challenge because i think if you
look at the way europe has handled this
crisis strategically you know the way
that i think emmanuel macron has been
slightly played by vladimir putin in
this crisis you know there are questions
about how ready europe is to take on
more responsibility for its own security
how do you think that putin sees an
opportunity in the sense that he
believes america is weakened uh
competitive was you know a few decades
ago where you think about russia in the
90s
um
there's you know some such as fiona hill
former adviser donald trump saying that
putin
effectively
sees
america as where russia was in the 90s
now
well he certainly knows that the balance
of power has shifted from where it was
say in the early post-cold war era when
russia was flat on its back and the
united states was simply unchallenged
and he's right about that america is
still by far the strongest country in
the world but its advantages are not as
pronounced as they were in the mid 1990s
or the mid 2000s and so particularly in
regions near russia's borders or near
china's borders for that for that matter
it gives autocratic powers greater room
for maneuver i think in the more
immediate crisis putin probably judged
that the united states wasn't so much
weak as distracted that it was desperate
for calm on non-asian fronts so it could
pay more attention to
the chinese challenge that may have
encouraged him to push a little bit
harder in ukraine calculating that he
would get a relatively weak response
james what role do you think nato
expansion has played in this do you
think that you can say that it has
led putin to take a more confrontational
um aggressive approach
i think what putin is really worried
about with ukraine is ukraine's you know
becoming successful democracy it's
western orientation i i think if you
took ukraine membership of nato off the
table that would not be enough for
vladimir putin but i think you also see
something else here which is
that putin is an opportunist not a
strategist one of the things he did with
the annexation of crimea is he changed
the political balance within ukraine to
make ukraine a more western orientated
country and i think that that is an
example of him failing to see things i
also think that what we are what we are
seeing is uh in ukraine is the dangers
of not being a nato member you know why
are the baltic states between our former
socialist republic soviet republics as
well why are they more secure because
they are covered by the nato nuclear
umbrella so you know if putin is trying
to suggest to countries that they
shouldn't join nato he's actually
providing a textbook demonstration of
why countries want to do this i also
think another risk here is that you know
ukraine famously gave up its nuclear
weapons at the end of the cold war i
think anyone watching what is happening
to ukraine will think well was that the
correct strategic decision it is they
are still your ultimate guarantor of
safety how what do you think is the
thing or the factor that would be the
most impactful in causing putin to
stop uh
think again recalibrate perhaps take a
different path i mean you've seen
western leaders um
almost being quite coordinated this week
questioning his judgment suggesting he's
acting in a deranged manner um do you
think that could have any effect
well i don't know if he's deranged or
not but i think it is entirely possible
that when you take the use of military
force off the table which i think was a
reasonable thing to do
that there just may not be
a combination of costs that the west can
generate that would prevent putin from
going ahead with further aggression
within ukraine putin may simply have
decided that whatever economic costs or
whatever diplomatic costs the united
states and others can impose on him
are not greater than the cost that he
would suffer if he allowed ukraine to
continue to develop as a democracy and
and draw closer to the west and so he
may simply simply be operating in los
aversion territory here which drives him
to do relatively aggressive things now
putin may be miscalculating he he may
misunderstand the extent to which he is
going to promote a more vigorous more
united nato with greater u.s and
european military presence on his
borders he may be underestimating the
effect which he's pushing countries like
finland and sweden to rethink their
status vis-a-vis nato and perhaps
eventually to join that alliance and so
he may be wrong but that may not do us
any good in the current crisis and james
um just uh reaching the end of this
discussion do you think there's a chance
that after weeks of you know the uk
particularly but you know other allies
to talking really tough about action
they're going to take they were now
entering the stage given that putin is
taking action we expect that he could go
further that
certain countries and perhaps west in
general starts to look quite impotent
i think hal is right that we are seeing
if you are not prepared to use military
force there is limits to how much
leverage you have especially given that
putin is convinced first of all the west
is not prepared to boycott russian
energy supplies and secondly that putin
thinks that the western public are not
prepared to take a kind of prolonged
pain you know it was quite clear in that
that bizarre televised national security
council meeting on monday that you know
that putin has convinced himself that
when it comes to sanctions you know a
russia can ride them out and b the west
is not prepared to take as much pain on
itself as it would need to be for these
sanctions to be you know to be truly
devastating to the russian economy so i
think that there are challenges there
but i also think that
uh the opportunity for the west
is to uh
it is more united i don't think people
would have expected germany to cancel
nordstrom 2 in the way that it would
have done even a few months ago so if
the west can respond in a more united
fashion than expected i think it could
has the potential to impose deeper
economic consequences on russia than
putin was perhaps expecting and i think
the other thing that you saw on that
monday meeting is putin is not someone
who is listening to anybody else right
now this was not someone interested in
listening to bad news or caution and i
think that the other thing putin might
be underestimating is how determined
ukrainians are to fight and how just
finally um not quite ending on a cheery
note but i wondered what do you think is
a reasonable worst case scenario for the
west when it comes to the situation
going forward
well the worst case scenario is that you
get significant economic fallout from
sanctions and counter sanctions which
adds to inflationary pressures and which
starts to create cracks in the unity of
the west as people deal with the
prospect of prolonged economic pain but
but worse than that would be you get
further
escalation than cyber realm or perhaps
in the military realm out of the current
uh conflict that's not entirely
unthinkable i think that it's unlikely
this would lead to a clash between
russia and nato countries but you you
can trace paths by which that would
happen if if the united states and other
countries decide to provide arms to a
ukrainian insurgency and uh the russians
decide to try to stop that by clearing
out the insurgency sanctuaries across
the border in a nato state again i think
that that's unlikely but it is thinkable
and so we need to be imagining some of
these worst case scenarios james you're
going to stay with us hal thanks for
joining
in an address to the nation today the
prime minister said the uk and its
allies would continue to support ukraine
through sanctions and through providing
defense as weaponry
boris also labelled vladimir putin as
the dictator so what will the fight back
look like
and with most of europe dependent on
russian gas will it be a blowback
against britain's economy
kate andrews the spectator's economics
as he joins me and james to talk about
the latest in westminster
james
russia dominates in westminster this
week but is also
the return of mps after recess and it's
been a tricky a few months clearly for
boris johnson how's his position
changed as uh russia and ukraine has um
become the main issue of the day the
main issue of the day
well it has provided a different lead
story it has allowed boris jensen to be
the statesman on the world stage
i think up until the end the
announcement of the first tranche of
sanctions earlier this week boston had
quite a good crisis i think the general
reaction in parliament and among tory
mps too was that the first set of
sanctions the uk announced was
underwhelming now obviously there are
now going to be further sanctions
because russia has launched this all-out
assault on ukraine
but you know i think those initial set
of sanctions were underwhelming
obviously also on monday we had the
announcement that from today thursday
all the covered restrictions in england
are gone i think boris johnson wants to
put a thinks that is something that both
pleases his mps i think he also thinks
it will have economic benefits and there
is another
aspect of this which is you know if
covered restrictions are a thing of the
past i think some of those around him
hope that will take some of the
emotional energy out of the the
allegations about uh whether boris
johnson himself uh which i'll be knocked
out by the police while the borrower's
himself breached those covered rules uh
in downing street now
i mean there's only a limited amount of
truth to that in that people's emotional
experiences of lockdown are are still so
strong and still so recent in their
memories but i think that boy johnson
certainly hopes that having done that
uh he has put some credit in the bank
victoria mps one thing that those story
mps very close to boris johnson says you
know look on monday every tory mp's
contribution in that statement was
supportive and it's been a long time
since boris johnson has had that
and kate just briefly on sanctions
because we've got a lot of russia coming
up in this episode um can you talk us
through the economic impact that
sanctions like to have on the uk because
it's something biden's warned about but
we haven't heard so much about from
boris johnson on the issue
so
it's quite clear that from the original
statements that were made as james says
tory mps didn't think that the uk was
going far enough boris johnson would
probably say look i have to leave myself
some room in case things get worse which
they now obviously have done but there
was definitely a sense that those
sanctions weren't going to be most
acutely felt by the british people that
this was obviously uh sanctions that
were were meant to be um at the starting
baseline of what they otherwise could be
it was europe that was really going to
feel that economic pain particularly
germany deciding to um pause at least
the certification of the nordstrom 2
pipeline a really big moment actually
because that will have frustrated
vladimir putin quite a lot he was
expecting to get billions of dollars of
revenue out of that um now that was
going to cause a domestic crisis an
energy crisis for germany but now that
things are escalating and war is very
very real we can see the economic impact
far more clearly i mean oil is
skyrocketing it's now over a hundred
dollars a barrel and if we start to talk
about real sanctions really cutting
russia out of international markets and
in a very tough way that is obviously
going to have a knock-on impact on
consumers around the world and this is a
difficult time for governments to be
selling that line because we have
inflation going up the cost of living is
is definitely being felt acutely here in
the uk places like the us as well
people like biden looking at the
midterms uh his own possibility of
re-election these are tough arguments to
sell to a public because you know as you
crack down on trade you inevitably hurt
both sides but
uh i think there's definitely a sense in
the uk and certainly in the u.s
post-afghanistan and
the way that even during the 2020
election trump and biden were very much
in agreement that the u.s had to pull
back and stop being so much of the
world's policemen that these options are
better than putting boots on the ground
and actually going to war with russia
and james where's chris stamina in all
this because the labour lead is very
keen to talk about ukraine uh pushing
obviously borrowers johnson to go even
further on sanctions and what's he
trying to do here
i think kierst dahmer is trying to show
that labour is now a responsible
opposition and to put distance between
his labour party and and that of jeremy
corbyn um it is hard to imagine that
jeremy corbyn would be responding so
unequivocally to the situation in
ukraine i mean you can see in jeremy
corbyn's statements that kind of far
more suggestions that that nato
expansion has not been uh has provoked
this crisis and the like kirsten is
trying to say you know that is not how
he thinks and he's trying to stress you
know his seriousness look at the fact
that he's visited nato during this
crisis uh and and the like i think there
is an interesting political question
here which is as kate says this is
obviously going to make the cost of
living crisis worse energy prices are
going to go up higher pet prices at the
petrol pump are going to go higher um
how does the public think about that
does the public think uh does the public
feel
more angry with the government because
it's real
real take-home income is continuing to
is falling more sharply or do the public
think well look this is this is this is
because of russia's decision to invade
ukraine
and kate uh you've mentioned how clearly
war's going to have an economic impact
and but bigger picture i suppose in
terms of the long-term plan rishi scenic
has given a lecture this week can you
tell us what he's been saying
sure so the chancellor gave what on the
surface is quite a technical business
lecture but i think is the closest we've
gotten so far to a rishi sunek manifesto
and there have been a lot of questions
over the past few months with the prime
minister ridden with scandal about if
there were to be a successor who would
that be and rishi's sunac is always
towards the top of the list so this is
the first time that we're really getting
a sense not of how he would act in an
emergency which has defined his time as
chancellor so far but if he were
actually in charge if he got to oversee
the economy in the way that he wanted to
do so in far better circumstances what
would he do and he essentially has laid
out his proposals to tackle the
productivity puzzle how do we generate
more growth how do we make the uk more
productive and he cites capital people
and ideas and and really the idea behind
here is that um while the tory party at
the moment is so focused on spending
more money especially on the national
health service rishi sunak is more
focused on investing in education i
think that's where he would like to see
more funds go but crucially he does not
think that government spending is the
way that you're going to generate a
better economy it's a false god
according to the speech that he gives
and again it's very technical but if you
were to peel back some of those
technicalities and really get to what
he's saying he's convinced that you
can't just have tax cuts that you're not
accounting for he basically says you
know tax cuts aren't enough i'm not
convinced that they will always pay for
themselves you have to tackle spending
too you have to be fiscally responsible
and then you have to figure out how to
generate more growth he wants to look at
tax cuts that would generate more
capital investment he wants to look at
tax cuts around a.i and those
technological innovations that he thinks
would be so good for the economy but
it's a very pro free market speech and i
think a lot of tories in particular will
be interested in that because there has
been this increasing divide between the
chancellor and frankly the rest of
cabinet a party conference last year
where they were all talking about low
taxes and small state and rishi sunak
was the only one who was basically not
willing to use those words because let's
be frank we have the highest tax burden
in 71 years kobet has not been the time
of the small state he's been the one to
say look i'm actually focused on trying
to balance the books because it's the
only way i think that we can generate
economic prosperity in the future but he
really embraces the free market and i
think a lot of tories were wondering
look is this guy actually far more
centrist than we thought and is he maybe
closer to new labor than he actually is
to the tory party not according to this
speech he quotes adam smith he fully
embraces the market economy uh and i
think a lot of tourists are probably
optimistic to hear that um and it is
interesting to see sort of what the
sunac agenda might look like this is the
first time really that we see his vision
for the future not just how he handles
emergencies and james just finally um we
have a situation where there's a lot of
pressure and expectation amongst tory
mps and i would say a large chunk of the
cabinet that the tories start cutting
taxes ahead of the next election um this
is what's been saying income tax could
be
where they go uh is there anything in um
rishi senate's you know blueprint which
uh suggests this is more likely or less
likely
but the speech is very much focused on
on business taxes rather than personal
taxation but i think i think it is clear
that he he wants to move to a kind of
lower tax system
but as kate says you know his argument
is you've got you've got to pay for that
through uh and that has got to involve
spending restraint you know in this in
this divide between you know thatcher
and reagan thatcher felt you had to get
the public finances under control before
you could cut taxes reagan famously said
that the deficit was big enough to look
after itself uh he is clearly siding for
fatcher over reagan i i think leaving
aside all the ideological questions
there there is a simple pragmatic a
reason for this as well the u.s because
of the the dollar status as the global
reserve currency has far more fiscal
flexibility to go for deficit-funded tax
cuts than uh the uk does and i mean i
mean i mean that that is just a reality
that that people in this country
need to accept
thank you james thank you kate
now to covet the last of the covert
restrictions in the uk were lifted this
week
in the magazine matt ridley stands an
optimistic note we don't need to worry
about a deadly variant coming along and
because ultimately respiratory diseases
he says almost always get milder to
explain matt joins me now
matt thank you for joining us on
spectator tv this week to begin what did
you make of the prime minister's living
with covert plan that he unveiled this
week
well i think it's inevitable i think
it's the right thing to do and i think
it's a huge relief to a lot of people
we couldn't go on restricting people's
movements we couldn't go on basically
you know living under our authoritarian
regime when nanny knows best
and we don't have to that's the best
thing you know we've got to the point
where the omicron wave is fading
deaths didn't go anything like as high
as the official experts said just before
christmas um clearly this is a milder
version of the virus it's not much worse
than a cold it's probably about as bad
as a flu
and the fact that an awful lot of people
have had it now means that it's going to
struggle to spread as fast anyway so i
think we are through to the point where
this is much more like an endemic
influenza
and the world health organization's
david nabarro suggested it was the wrong
move to get rid of so many rules legal
rules um do you think the uk is seen as
an outlier
when it comes to the global picture on
covet
well i think if you look at the uk
versus other european countries we had a
an earlier and
pretty bad omicron wave
but because we'd opened up somewhat in
july last year and because we didn't
close down in december
the uk has got through this wave quicker
than other countries it's just not fair
of the world health organization and
others to sort of try and do a
one-size-fits-all recommendation for all
countries it's got to be country
specific and i think clearly britain has
reached the point um where it can start
to live with the virus because the the
the effect on people's
uh psychology their minds their lives of
living under intense restrictions with
people telling them what to do and what
not to do is not nothing it is a
significant effect
and in the magazines
matt you write about
what's going to happen or could happen
in terms of strains of the virus one of
the
arguments you hear against getting rid
of so many rules um is this uh idea that
we could have a new strain it could be
much worse it could be more dangerous um
what do you say to that
i think it's very unlikely that this
virus will mutate into a more
virulent strain
respiratory tract viruses viruses that
reflect the nose and throat
on the whole end up mild there are about
200 different kinds of virus that cause
the common cold none of them kill people
normally
all of them are mild you heard this week
that the queen has mild cold like
symptoms that's telling you colds are
mild now that's not a coincidence
not all viruses evolve milder forms by
no means insect-borne ones water-borne
ones
sexually transmitted diseases they can
go on killing and they can have variants
that that are more lethal but if you
think about it with a with a virus
that's spread by coughing and sneezing
on the whole it's going to spread much
faster if the person who
has it is feeling okay enough to go to
work to go to parties etc and that
effect that selective effect results in
an evolution towards milder forms in
respiratory viruses only yes it's
interesting what you say about human
behavior because i think if we think
about omicron and there was there was
very much as you highlight in your
article a reluctance to say it could be
mild there was lots of sense you know
saying there wasn't much reason to think
this but then one of the large uh
factors we've pointed to was vaccines as
a reason that it was less of a threat
but you argue actually often it can be
more than one thing and as you say
one of the factors behind this is this
idea that if you are very ill you're
more likely to stay at home
and that means that the
the more diluted or less strong variants
have a better chance of spread
that's right there's been a very strange
reluctance to admit that omicron uh is
mild the uh south africans who
discovered it found that they came under
great pressure not to say that um and we
heard a lot of denying of that early on
and then when it did appear that the
symptoms were milder we were told that's
just because people have an immune
protection through the booster vaccine
in particular
and that has obviously had a huge effect
but there is now
data published in nature showing that
that's not the only effect
there's also another effect which is
that the virus itself is intrinsically
milder
other things being equal it gives people
a milder version of
covet that's probably because it doesn't
migrate deeper into the lungs or into
the bloodstream it probably stays in the
nasal mucosa something like that
but whatever it is this is a milder
virus and that's to be expected that at
this point in the evolution of the virus
as long as people are as it were
free to decide whether they go out or
don't go out then the sicker people are
going to stay home or get tested
or whatever and the
less sick people are going to get are
going to
sorry let me say that again the less
sick people are going to test going to
go out and meet other people and so the
less strong variants are more likely to
spread than the strong ones so i think
it's very unlikely that you will see
this
virus turn virulent again
any more than you see
normal ordinary common colds turn
virulent
now
we can never be 100 sure what's going to
happen and you cite an exception uh to
this rule in your piece
the 1918 fluke can you talk uh viewers
through what happened there
yes so influenza is on the whole a
relatively mild disease not as mild as
colds and there's a reason for that it's
a it's a more durable virus but uh it
in the one exception is the 1918
epidemic and what happened there was
that it did start quite mild actually it
was only in august 1918 that it suddenly
mutated into a really lethal form that
started killing people now professor
paul ewald has studied this case as well
as others and he comes to the conclusion
that what happened there was that in the
peculiar conditions of the trenches
if a soldier got sick with influenza and
he was not too bad he would go to a
dugout and sleep it off and stay in the
trenches if he was really sick he'd be
taken by stretcher bearers to a field
hospital he'd then be put on a train
back to england
on a crowded troop ship etc etc
spreading it to lots and lots of people
and nurses effectively acting as sort of
vectors for the disease so the the
strong versions of the virus were
spreading better than the mild versions
of the virus now i worry that something
similar happened during lockdowns in
this country the early lockdowns in
particular
because in this pandemic i should say
because
although this you know this was an
intrinsically nasty virus
as they often are when they start off in
a new species
we weren't putting it under pressure to
get milder because we were telling mild
cases to stay at home and we were
sending
severe cases to hospitals where they
were more likely to infect healthcare
workers and other patients
and just finally matt it's interesting
in your piece you mentioned nerve tag as
well as a few other
scientific advisors during the pandemic
a nerve tag when uh ultimately they said
that it was a common misconception that
viruses
mutate to be less severe i just wondered
why do you think there has been such a
reluctance to even entertain this as
something that could happen obviously
we're never going to say
for certain there will never be a bad
strain again um but but it seems strange
in a way that within the community
there's been such a reluctance and you
mentioned south africa and omicron to
even go near it do you think it's
because they're worried about the public
relaxing or what is it
i think there's a natural bias towards
pessimism in these bodies because you
you you get into much more trouble if
you're too optimistic and you're wrong
than if you're too pessimistic and
you're too wrong but over and above that
i think there's a special problem here
which is that the kind of people being
consulted in these expert bodies on the
whole don't know much evolutionary
biology now that might seem a harsh
thing to say about senior biologists but
actually if you're a medical scientist
you don't get much training in darwinism
in understanding how these things work
it's quite subtle stuff and you have to
to dig under the surface and get to
understand how these things happen
understand the process of selection so
for example they always talk about the
virus mutating
well mutation is only a part of
evolution selection is the other part
you get mutants some get selected some
don't that's what drives evolution
and that part often gets left out
thank you matt thank you for coming on
today
canada's leader justin trudeau invoked
emergency powers this week in a bid to
stop protests against vaccine mandates
in the country
truckers who had formed cues to block
supply routes into canada found their
bank accounts frozen and were declared
terrorists by the government
what is truday thinking to try and work
that out i'm joined now by spectator
contributor megan murphy
megan thanks for joining us on spectator
tv canada is still in a state of
emergency over a trucker's protest can
you update viewers on what's been going
on
so the chakras have now been cleared out
of ottawa um
prime minister justin trudeau invoked
the emergencies act which has never been
invoked before in the history of canada
um at one point it was called the war
measures act and was a vote invoked back
in 1970 by his father actually pierre
trudeau
um but it's meant to be used
in
the case of a an extreme emergency um
and
so
for example in the 70s when pierre
trudeau
invoked the war measures act it was to
deal with a terrorist group who had
actually murdered and kidnapped a
politician and in this case we're
dealing with a protest in ottawa um led
by working-class people by regular
canadians there was no violence
it was a peaceful protest
they were dancing in the streets they
were barbecuing they were singing the
national anthem they were playing street
hockey
um and
it was you know it's it's really
shocking that he's he's taken it to this
extreme and and quite scary in my
opinion
and what's the reaction of the general
public how have canadians reacted um to
the escalation by trudeau
i mean it's hard to say uh i can
based on my social media feeds for
example
i can see that
it's strange because a lot of leftists
have been
very much opposed to the protests in
ottawa
and the protests have been framed by the
media and the left
as a an extreme right protest as you
know they've been labeled terrorists in
some cases i've seen people label them
treasonists um and they've definitely
been labeled anti-vaxxers over and over
again
and you know
the people at the protest are not
anti-vaxxers they're certainly not
terrorists they're
very diverse in terms of politics and
and ethnicity
um
and they really just want their rights
back they want their lives back they
want their freedoms back they want their
charter rights back
and we're opposing the mandates and
restrictions that were ongoing and
mostly nonsensical and unnecessary at
this point
but you know a lot of the leftists
strangely have supported
authoritarianism in all of this so
what the emergencies act does is it
removes people's civil rights and it
allows justin trudeau to do things like
freeze people's bank accounts and he has
done that he's frozen the bank accounts
of leaders of the protests but also of
some people who donated to the protest
to the convoy
and
you know people should first of all be
allowed to donate money to whatever they
want to donate money to it's none of the
government's business but it's
it's just
it's a really
specific and scary form of punishment
when you can take away somebody's
ability to survive because of their
political views or beliefs essentially
and it's very strange to me that the
left of all people have been supporting
this it seems to me that the left had
become very much opposed to the working
class and very much the elitists in many
ways i saw some leftists on my my social
media accounts sharing one one meme one
tweet
um a lot yesterday that was mocking the
protesters for being uneducated um you
know
saying things like oh it's really it's
really nice that they held a grad party
for people who never graduated from high
school and i just was like can you hear
yourselves who have you become
um you don't support free speech anymore
you don't support diversity um you're
completely intolerant of people who are
different than you
and you're denigrating people who are
less privileged than you essentially
now this week has seen the uk announce
and then to all uh covert restrictions
do you think there's a chance of seeing
anything like that in canada anytime
soon or does it feel very far away i
mean for many of the reasons that we're
currently discussing well it's
interesting because as soon as the
protests began or shortly thereafter in
any case across the provinces the
mandates and restrictions were being
dropped so at the provincial level
premiers were deciding due to this
political pressure to drop the vaccine
passports um to drop the mask mandates
to drop the restrictions around
socializing
and so on and so forth but at the
federal level
justin trudeau and the liberal party are
still clinging to these mandates so
despite the fact that it seemed as
though canada was moving on promise to
province to province
um justin trudeau seems to be
maintaining and
it's almost i i can't say for sure why
but it almost seems like an ego thing he
doesn't want to to lose this war
um you know we're seeing around the
world the mandates and restrictions
are being dropped and people are moving
on with their lives
and canada
appears to be going in the opposite
direction in some ways so it did seem
like things were getting better and then
suddenly things got exponentially
worse when justin trudeau decided to
invoke the emergencies act
thank you megan thanks for joining us
today
that's it for this week once again the
spectator is delighted that canaccord
genuity wealth management is sponsoring
the week in 60 minutes canaccord will
provide the expertise you need to build
your wealth of confidence you can visit
can do wealth dot com to find out more
and if you enjoyed this episode don't
forget to subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel just click the subscribe
button at the bottom of this video and
tap the bell icon so you never miss an
episode
thanks for watching and do join us again
next week
[Music]
you